[Music]
thank you thank you thank you for having
me
or thank you for coming whichever I
don't know which I don't know who's in
charge whose party is this
maybe that tall guy they say the biggest
fear in America is Heights and public
speaking those are the biggest fears oh
I don't know I think we can all agree
our biggest fear is being tipped over
while sitting in a port-a-potty I went
to the doctor recently just for no just
for shits and giggles because I figure
those happening at the same time there's
got to be something wrong I am part
Native American I just found out I wish
I'd known before college it's not by
blood actually I'm part Native American
because my mom used a dreamcatcher
as a diaphragm and you never know where
you're gonna capture I look like this
guy blue eyes what a ripoff my roommate
says that I brush my teeth gay all right
what thoroughly I brush them thoroughly
but gay come stop get out of the
bathroom like put on a shirt why are you
watching okay here's how I brush my
teeth just like you guys I get my brush
and I just brush it and then I get his
brush and I just kind of do that for
about five minutes and then I squirt
toothpaste on my chest
my broad sculpted hairless chest
that's right sculpted I'm like a skull
butcher I was told that in me at a
museum I write when I walked in the lady
was like wow you have the body of
Michelangelo's David yeah I get it
you know I am very muscular I'm quite
pale very smooth and I'm missing most of
my penis nah come on it's all there
works great I just I say the wrong thing
when it goes off like you know towards
the end of sex where you're breathing
hard and you want to say something sweet
but you're out of breath so you get all
Tourette's II like though you're a
pretty lady or another example I have a
pretty good one I've been using it but
it's getting mixed reviews from the
ladies so I figure I'll just run it by
you right now right towards the end
where you're breathing hard and it's
important I like to go I'm gonna go
number three it's very specific
[Applause]
I like ya maja I like count pretty good
segue I let go Yamaha Yamaha makes
motorcycles and then also pianos same
logo exactly same Factory
I guess motorcycles and pianos hi Yamaha
hey way to nail a non-existent
demographic just know just one Asian guy
with a mullet operating a ferris wheel
preparing mentally for his concerto or
concerto whichever fourth way you want
to say that while he pops a sweet a
sweetly that's change you guys like soup
of course yeah
who's right Campbell's or I mean
Campbell's or Campbell's either one a
lot of people are like I like Campbell's
Chunky what why it's sick you can eat
that with a fork get out of here
Campbell's Chunky that's thicker you can
eat that with a stick or a car key if
you're desperate you're probably in a
ditch somewhere crying you don't have
OnStar you bought a Kia
[Laughter]
well oh uh here's a character one door
closes another one opens that's my
impression of a guy trying to stay
positive while living in a haunted house
thank you no you're not wrong to clap
I'm gonna wrap it up here be funny right
then I put on a condom but I uh we've
had some fun laughs we've laughed about
50% of this I want to leave you with
something serious though if I could just
get your other than the one where your
teeth are falling out and you look down
your hands are melting and then you look
down and your lower body is that of a
horse other than that one it's important
to follow your dreams thank you thank
you
[Applause]